I was in this period of cyto sensus
iido other people will be in this period
other people will be before my period
And as cyto Sensi develops and changes
his body his iido changes so I was
taught that when you do this the
foot and the cup come
together they've tried to change me over
the years
to step cut because it gives you better
balance and you build
mass okay so they'll
go but you see that doesn't sit with me
because I was in the era
where you your foot and cut goes
together so I can't get rid of that cuz
I was taught it by cyto Sensi in those
days so what I say to people is look you
step and cut because you got mass and I
agree with you because I see most people
that they don't have mass you when Danny
holds me I can tell he's got Mass but a
lot of you don't have
mass so I've decided over the years I'm
going to keep that timing because that
send me you know that send me to where I
am today
then what I didn't see what cyto Sensi
kept saying was Ronnie what I didn't see
from cyto sensy
was please go past and only just you see
if if we're on this line and I say to R
please please go past see I'm still on
the line he actually get off the
line so it finally twigged I don't know
how many years since he must it but when
he says Doo
see Ronnie stayed on the line and I got
off the line so that's the second thing
that I really treasured because it took
me so long to
understand but some of you might like
that and say I'm going to make that like
in my Bible now don't matter what any
other teacher tells me I'm going to be
stubborn and stick with that if any of
you are tell me you're not stubborn
you're not from this
planet so so so in other words you build
your iido on beliefs or else you're
going to be following teachers forever
if you think that they're going to give
you the answer they're not you got
so all of these techniques that we learn
today I've
got timing of body and feet so watch
this foot on this one watch this right
foot on this
one can cut timing feet now I'm not
saying these other teachers are wrong
all I'm saying is they were taught in a
different era and theirs is more I think
it's better for the student to
learn but I don't want to be the student
anymore I want to be Tony and I want to
be good so I have to break out of being
a student always going please sensey
please Sensei teach me and I have to be
Tony who's Tony you know so so so I've
got the I've got the timing but now I've
got go well please go past Ronnie if I
sort of if I say please go past but I've
got to do this technique so I can't let
you too much space then I'm not
believing in what I should be doing so
here I go
do and and I'm holding him
off you can't feel it but I'm holding
him off from coming in and just keeping
enough there that
okay so that's you know I'd love to see
some of you get that because I've got it
through being
me and not realizing God blind me I've
heard him say that so many times I
didn't realize the essence of
it all right control come up
come
up no keep coming don't don't get don't
get
tired all right you don't know what's
going on in my head and I'm like I'm
like Fork lightning I'm down there I'm
going I'm working out every twitch he's
doing I'm working our electrical
angle all right so a bit too heavy for
today isn't it
but so if you think you're turning over
but then it goes over that way a little
bit you're not actually getting out the
way cuz then you bring it back here and
it might be subtle but that's what as a
teacher I'm trying to give
you
subtlety okay so we'll try again
uh you don't have to think exactly what
I think but you know make sure you're
not in their way they should they should
be able to keep going and you should be
able to uh do the
technique there's this
one there's this one where I'm still
getting out the way but the right timing
that one comes
in so you can play around I don't care
how many variations I see I normally see
a lot of variations when you're trying
to do it my way anyhow don't